condone entire Coach's Corner the
Dodgers manager Dave Roberts joins us
skip how are you today
a victory will do that for you but if
you were gonna try to sum up what's
happened so far how would you sum it up
I would say shockingly surprising
inconsistent that's probably it
but you guys have outscored the
opposition you're the only team that
with a losing record that's outscored
the opposition so as it just come down
to pitching the injuries you know what
and I and we haven't used that at all
because I think that every team has
certain injuries Danna and you know that
and we know that and I believe in the
guys that we have healthy I really do
but I just think that yeah you look at
those numbers and how we've kind of the
run differential thing and it just
doesn't make sense but the bottom line
is you know whatever the run
differential plays you got you got to
find ways to win baseball games and a
lot of the guys that we have now we're
part of that team last year they went to
the World Series so III think you'll
even itself out correct itself and
getting JT back certainly is a big lift
and there's a lot of season left
definitely a sense of urgency but I
expect us to turn things around how did
you react when you heard that you got a
vote of confidence from management no
you know what it's always good to have
support you know I think the one thing
though Dan is
we have to stick together all of us you
know players coaches staff management
ownership and we I believe in the
process obviously they believe in what
we're doing here on the field and it's a
good thing yeah
Clayton Kershaw status throughout 220
feet yesterday and then yesterday before
again he was letting it rip so we're
talking about trying to get him off the
mound here at some point soon I know
that sort of vague but he's pain-free
right now and now we're just trying to
let the progress kind of just take care
of itself but it's very promising to get
him back soon you got a lot of season
left but do you feel like what are the
expectation level what is it now as
opposed to what it was when the start
and the season started I don't think
that's changed you know and to be quite
honest you know you look at our division
which i think is a very talented
division but the way we play for the
first month and a half I think that you
look at the standings we could be a lot
worse off to be quite honest and so you
look at where we're at and I just don't
see how that's not a candle to still
whether station how do you stay upbeat
and try to convince everybody don't
panic I think the thing is is that it's
just easier for all of us and to focus
on each day and that's frustrating as a
season has been for all of us each day
to focus on one major league game and
for me that's easy and to kind of try to
forecast and get ahead of it that really
can't control it you can't control it so
I think for me by nature I'm positive
and the players are playing their asses
off I mean they're playing their tails
off they are and they're preparing so
for me as as a manager or the coach is
we come in fresh every day and that's
pretty easy actually
when yesterday over the Marlins you got
the Nationals coming up tonight weather
permitting Dave Roberts Dodgers manager
do you look at the weather is that first
thing you look at when you're when
you're on the road
there's a when you were you when you
hear about the weather in DC that that's
something that yet better kind of Stacey
was because potentially you got to talk
pitching and how you can get manipulate
that you got to potentially talk about a
doubleheader how that kind of changes
and using your pen I use JT which I was
going to probably try to sit him
yesterday but anticipated we might have
off day-to-day with the rain I played
him yesterday and fortunately we did so
yeah I kind of look at that a little bit
yeah who does Bryce Harper remind you of
and maybe a previous generation you know
what this is a this is loose obviously
but I'm just saying it's kind of the
Barry Bonds thing and obviously I'm not
comparing the two but it's the question
you ask me in the sense that there's a
big drop-off in player with everyone
around them and no disrespect the other
guys with this guy with one swing can
really hurt you and he seems like he's
always coming up in big spots so that
guy he's just he's just more talented
than everyone you know around him and
and Barry was the same way so it kind of
in that sense probably Barry I guess if
you raced all the current managers first
to third
how would you do okay who would
challenge you here Dave alright I think
that who would challenge me I think Alex
Cora Gabe Kapler no I think I got out
okay some Tabler she about to Kapler
capper I think it could get me I would
say the the younger fleet of foot
probably Andy drink he'd get me outside
of that I'm gonna I'm gonna finish I'm
gonna summon a place I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go third who would finish last
who would finish less bugs for sure
right right poaches finished last
I think snitcher can get votes could you
hook certainly laughs could you laughs
Scioscia first 2/3 clapping I might get
it slaps oh yeah can you beat how many
of your players could you beat just
going home to first I could beat
Yasmani Grondahl I could beat him right
you could beat him I can't beat Kent but
temps into the shape now so I'm gonna go
maybe I like to race kenley jansen see
what we got there but could you maybe or
Shawn could you beat Kershaw absolutely
oh no way no chance
really yeah no chance not anymore maybe
maybe a couple years ago but now I took
it get the last couple of years dan
Kenley is 65 to 75 yeah former catcher I
got to be able to beat him is how do we
bring the steals back you know what
that's a that's a that's a good question
I think part of it is you're talking
about the players that are playing in
the big leagues the profile now a player
is a different player that's drafted and
playing it's more that guy that's being
that's lugging and that you know Juan
Pierre type player Rafael Furcal those
guys are just not around as much anymore
that's what part of it but I obviously
like that dynamic a flair yeah I just
think if the game there's no movement in
the game anymore
it's just it's either strikeout or a
home run and when we were growing up you
know you had the extra base you did move
a guy over I think this is the one
downside the biggest downside I have
with baseball
they're just not any movement yeah yeah
and I and I agreed yet and I think that
there's a deeper issue with that and you
look at and I'm on the you know
competition committee for Major League
Baseball and the pipeline committee
which is diversity in basement if you
look at the numbers also this is a
deeper issue with like african-american
players in baseball and you know guys I
can really run we're having less
african-american players in the game and
we're working on that
but it's a different type of profile of
player and I like the action I like the
kind of the cat Mouse you know the guy
that could steal a base and you know
another thought is the inside move at
second base you know if you can
eliminate the inside move which we're
talking about potentially you know it's
it's as the rule stage is deceiving the
runner at second base so that might
incentivize guys to steal more and
quicken up at second base which would
take away some of the stuff from the
pitcher from delivery standpoint you
know to then get more runners you know
balls and play things like that so
whereas as a group as an industry really
trying to talk about some things Buster
only of ESPN said within five years
we're gonna have a digital strike zone
what do you think I I think that that's
that's fair you'd be okay with that
right I would I would and and I think
that you know obviously having the
umpire behind home plate is important
and is a necessity but to have you know
with technology when this game was
invented and created we didn't have the
technology we do so as life and the
world evolves I think that this game is
evolving and that's probably the next
step certainly how's the winery doing
how's the winery business winery red
stitch but Danna stood good we're moving
wine I'm not drinking as much out why
these days but you should be straight
whiskey
no man our wineries are great rich
Aurilia go red yeah Parker mine and he's
doing a great job selling the wine so
it's great thank you for ask are you a
wine snob though days I am a wine snob I
am I am Dan I'm a wine snob and you know
what I think I'm very particular and I
think that it's not about what's good
and what's not good is about what you
like and I'm particularly with what I
like and I'm particularly with watches
I'm particularly with who I hang out
with so I I but in the sense of the word
the definition I'm a wine stop okay
if we are you one of those guys that do
you look at it do you swirl it around do
you talk about the ten oh no if we're a
dinner okay are you gonna be doing that
okay listen here's the deal dan yes we
are
well we're gonna be talking about sports
we're gonna be talking about family
we're gonna be talking about travel you
know and it's gonna be a three-hour
sitting you know and that's a good thing
so we're gonna go to a few bottles of
wine and let's make this happen
yeah but you know if I go out with Bochy
we're just having a pitcher of beer yeah
you're right he's gonna whine and you're
gonna you know graduate to some some
harder stuff right but the thing is
you'll remember by night boat right not
I would love to tap into that though
with you know somebody who knows wine
when you go and then they run down the
menu but you can't do that like smelling
it and then putting your mouth and then
like swishing it around and then tell me
about the legs you're not you don't have
a bucket there to the side like you
don't spit it into a bucket or anything
like that right my stomach is alright
have fun on your night off it looks like
rain in the forecast that might be a
good thing with Strasse marry and then
who do you got you need the night off
with that right
start drinking now although I think skip
if you got hey thanks for joining us
Dave we appreciate your time
all right that's Dave Roberts Dodgers
manager he's been great every time we've
been on has some fun but he's got a
winery with Richard really it's called
red stitch Continental Tire coaches
corner brings you
Dave Roberts Continental Tire the
extreme contact sport is Continental
tires newest ultra high performance
summer tire tested to the limits by five
championship drivers check it out
they've thought of everything wet
conditions dry they're doing it on a
race track whether it's a Sunday Drive
or the open road or you are on the
racetrack it's the tire for what you do
visit Cottenham tire comm for more
details for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]